hyundai was uh caught for using child  labor of course why they got plenty of  koreans who are a child korean kids  here's the twist  it's a hyundai subsidiary plant that's  located in alabama  oh we're using white people  hell yeah let's go how's it feel whitey  the tables have turned no time for  little league i guess  my words that's a third world state  though like cambodia prices be honest  with you this is the most woke thing  i've ever heard in my life you think  that [ __ ] asian people have sweat  shops let me show you alabama yeah boom  woke up hopefully they're getting paid  school credit i don't think you know how  uh child labor works they get paid they  usually don't yeah they do oh they give  him a [ __ ] a can of tuna or some [ __ ]  tuna's good sardines wait i don't know  how you're going to feel about this the  kids weren't white  what were they i think they were  guatemalan oh  [Music]  we're so [ __ ]  up so funny never had little